luke
luke it's hard to guard a player if
there's no player near you
we good in the hood this is a uniquely
frustrating group of boys i hear you um
one thing that might help instead of a
zone if you switch to a simple
man-to-man i got this really because
according to the scoreboard the only
thing you got is four points
good luck
i need to talk to you i need to talk to
you
this time
you
cam cam you have got to relax i told you
i wouldn't take a job
what i want you to take the job
i thought you liked having me home with
with lily i i don't i mean i do i just i
miss my time with lily and i know it's
selfish i want the job
you do oh my god yes i
i love lily but i hate baby talk i love
baby talk
oh let's go get this let's get this job
okay
oh no
it's
oh locked guys
oh my gosh they're not gonna hear us
we're trapped out here no just stop
being so dramatic we'll just go through
the garage that's why he wants to hire
you you're good in crisis oh geesh what
it's not opening push it again well i'm
i'm hearing things but it's not harder
that's not is it this one i hear
something what is that
no stop touching something
this oh that was it all right
mitchell oh my god oh my god no cam cam
did we do that what are we gonna say oh
oh
i will take the job
kind of think you have to now yeah
guys you're on the same team
time out
time out
get over here
guys
earlier we practiced a few set plays did
any of them involve wrestling the ball
from your own teammate but you said to
be aggressive yeah and on your own team
wait here
you got a coach i can't take it
you talking to me yeah i'm talking to
you you got to take over i'm about to
lose it out there yeah that sounds tough
coach what's your problem hey coach
i was dealing with the coach you pushed
me aside i was dealing with the boys you
pushed me aside believe it or not jay
there are some things that i am better
at than you are bam it's out there oh
for god's sake coach
he's calling you let's i don't blame you
for being angry right i'm used to taking
charge that's all
i should have let you coach from the
get-go
and
i love you no the barbecue for god's
sake
i'm sure your steaks would have been
delicious and not chewy
okay i'll do it thanks
and so the student becomes the master
once again
no no no no i'm good i'm good i'm good
hey guys who wants to go out like a
champ yes i love it okay jordy you
inbound to luke manny you set a pick on
luke's man and roll to the bucket luke
you know what to do
no i don't
that's passed to manny but dad
coach
minnie hasn't taken a single shot all
season and chances are he'll be open
okay guys let's bring it out hey hey
bring it in
let's show these guys what kind of team
they're about to beat huh little
dribblers on three one two three
okay red ball side out here we go
what's my coaching philosophy
give a kid a bird
yes
and he becomes one of those weird dudes
who walks around with a bird on his
shoulder
[Music]
unless he has absolutely no hand-eye
coordination
okay
i support you
[Music]
you